if you get out of a bad relationship you
should learn evolutionary psychology
about what women actually biologically
want from you and about attachment you
should learn those things red pill is
right now the only place where men can
speak these old truths that fathers
would have said to their sons like well
son let me tell you about women red pill
is the only area men can go to hear that
now because we don't have relationships
with our fathers or grandfathers or
uncles anymore we don't have male only
spaces red pill is the only area where
they can do that
you've been everywhere these last few
months
i have man my feet are getting tired
from running across the internet so much
yeah it's serious you're on michaela's
show and that one crushed it as well
oh man that one was fun that one was
good too i launched from you on michaela
and i started doing all kinds of other
stuff with people and i started a
youtube channel i don't even know where
i am half the time now that's unreal so
the last episode we did was based off a
huge tweet thread you had about harsh
psychology truths and i've just scraped
a bunch of other ones that i want to go
through today what is it
what is it that you're drawing on when
you
pull out the tweets that you put into
that thread is it professional
experience is it just stuff that you
observe in social interactions where are
they coming from
a lot of it's a blend so i've done a lot
of study i'm specifically a behaviorist
myself with some cognitive pieces a
behaviorist i focus on the organism and
the organism is always right according
to bf skinner so if we have a behavior
that we're doing there's a purpose to it
what we have to do is figure out what
that purpose is what is that behavior
doing for us that's what a lot of my
tweets are based on is what could this
behavior be adapting to and why was the
organism right when they did it a lot of
people get really mad when they hear
that and they realize what their
behavior might be doing and what they
might be solving with those things man
i've had some mad people i've even had
some politicians from other nations
jumping in on that tweet thread talking
about how i'm a dangerous lunatic but
you know what it's helping a lot of
people too but you're a dangerous pulse
from
dangerous lunatic that was a
psychotherapist for how many years
oh a few but yeah i mean there's a lot
of bad therapists i can't blame them for
that
but i don't know it is what it is i pull
from my that research that i've done i
pull from a lot of practical experience
i treated uh i treated inmates up for
the death penalty i treated people
multiple murderers people with mutilated
children
um plus just people who are in for like
some political crimes and stuff like
that too you'd be amazed who's who's in
the jail system i i've treated families
in-home treatment for people disabled
with mental illness i've treated
and i've treated millionaire
entrepreneurs i've treated
homeless people people addicted to every
substance or activity that you can
imagine i've got a lot of experience so
when i'm writing these tweets it's
pulled from research that i've done and
experiences that i've had are they every
every single one of them 100 right in
every circumstance with no exceptions
now that's not how the internet works
but
you know what i stand by what i write
nice let's get into it man so the first
one you're not unlovable you just don't
believe you deserve love and commitment
and you pick partners who treat you the
way you expect to be treated what's that
mean
this is this is at the core of
attachment and that's one of the biggest
pieces of work that i do now when we our
kids our brain
learns from our parents specifically if
we deserve their love and their
attention mother and father biological
it doesn't matter who else is in the
picture if the dad is gone our brain
says i didn't deserve his love or he'd
be here with me right now if the parents
are there but they're neglecting you
they're abusing you the brain just as a
little kid says i deserve whatever is
happening i'm causing this everyone's
responding to me in some way there must
be something wrong with me inside
everybody else can see that i can't see
and i gotta act accordingly so you go
out in the world with this belief that
you are operating in a deficit with
everybody else so you have to find
people who need help so you can help
them and earn love from them by doing
the right things healthy people will see
that behavior and they'll see your
insecurities and they'll they'll kind of
back off a little bit they might try to
help a little bit but they'll back off
because they don't want to form a deep
bond with you because it's it's almost
impossible to build a lasting stable
relationship with someone like that
because the other person is never going
to be honest with you or open up to you
about what they need it's going to
fracture this is where the majority of
divorces come from is this attachment
issue
so healthy people will back off but
unhealthy people will say yeah come meet
my needs and and you'll mash up that way
so then you form a a
self-perpetuating cycle of
everybody treats me like crap i must
deserve to be treated like crap oh wait
this new person makes me feel really
good because i can earn their love by
fixing their problems and and making
them a star or whatever it is
and you just keep going and going going
and then you build a constant bias and
you look back over your life and when
someone like me comes along and says no
that's not right that's not healthy
behavior there's an alternative they say
no there's not i've been doing this for
35 years and everybody has treated me
like crap everybody
that's the system
do people tend to
like the opportunity to get love that's
contingent it sounds there like it's i i
feel like i'm loved because or i feel
like i am worthy because i have the
ability to fix this person the ability
to help this person
that is the only thing that they
understand they don't understand that
there is unconditional love for them
because they do not believe it's
possible because it did not come from
the two people on earth who should have
loved them unconditionally one or both
of those people their parents didn't
give them that what they need so nobody
else on earth is going to treat you
better than your parents that's the
assumption of the brain and then they
just go out in life and they become
adults and they never question
the immutable laws that they came to
believe when they were kids it just
never comes up they never stop and think
why do i think i don't deserve love it's
gravity pulls things down and i'm an
unlovable piece of crap that's just how
it goes how much or how effective is it
let's say that the father is out of the
picture and the mother remarries very
quickly
how uh supplantable is the biological
father with another father figure
it's not he's not i've seen that i've
seen that many many times what has to
happen is it must be verbally addressed
you have to take the child aside and
help them understand attachment when
someone understands attachment and
what's happening they can start to
question those ideas and they can they
can
come to some understanding a new
understanding and heal it you can heal
the child but that biological father is
not replaceable and it won't just
magically you can't just pop one dad in
and pop another dad out you can't just
do that it doesn't work that way because
the brain knows somewhere out there is a
biological father who is not with that
child and there's a reason he's not with
that child and if he loved the child
enough he would be there and the brain
keeps repeating that over and over and
over no matter how much the stepdad is
wonderful and and loving and caring
you can't address it like i said and fix
it take some time
but it's hard
all right next one
i [ __ ] love this one
too many red pill alpha guru types take
advantage of attachment issues to score
cash from wounded men and encourage them
to embrace their attachment wounds even
further it turns into a cult of people
convinced their wounds are scare are
sacred truths
man i catch a lot of flak because people
come in at me and say that's not what
red pill is about and and they're right
it's not red pill is supposed to be
evolutionary psychology applied to
relationships so that you can be healthy
and love each other love your wife love
your husband based on biological
imperatives within men and women that's
what it's supposed to be
in effect when you become a red pill
guru to make money off of these people
you say
no dude you're right women are scum
they'll never really love you they're
just there for the things you do for
them so you should just make them do
good things for you and take advantage
of those insecure women have sex with
them on the first date and never call
them again because screw them that's
what they're teaching and those guys
come in believing there's nothing better
and they hear that message and say wow
they feel like i feel but they're
turning it around i'm not the piece of
crap everybody else is the piece of crap
so it's okay the eye they owe me they
owe me this so they
go out and start using that and all that
does is create a whole society of damage
hurt women who go back and act exactly
the same and those nice guys
get hurt and then start looking for the
red pill community and say man all these
terrible things have happened it's a
self-perpetuating cycle between men and
women and that's all it is you don't
stop it until you fix the actual
problems which is not what red pill
gurus do to make money well the
equivalent to make money
the equivalent on the female side is
radical feminism right it's not
it's not as if red pill is the only root
to this there is a an equal polarity on
the other side of the fence which is man
i've i've gone on to some of the reddit
threads i can't remember what they're
called
it's not women's rights
it's not our slash women's rights but
it's one of those it might be the female
red pill or something like the other
pink pill or some [ __ ] and um you go on
there and you think
this is this is just as bad
as what you see in some of the meninism
manosphere spaces
it is it is and you know what it doesn't
have to be and my areas i mean i'm i'm
in touch with all kinds of like
masculinity coaches and all the like
cringe-worthy names that you would have
and some of them are the best men you
would ever meet who actually pull men up
out of this and say no dude fix your
behavior you're finding bad women
because you are a bad man and they make
the men fix themselves women there's
some women doing the same thing on their
side trying to fix it until you have
that fix between the balance of the
sexes and get back to our biological
imperatives and and understand what they
mean and and fix them and fix the
attachment now that's going to get
better but yeah man there's
there are grifters on both sides and
they are happy to take advantage of
those attachment issues they will take
all your money all day long and tell you
that what you're feeling is normal and
that you should embrace it and get worse
so you can pay them more man i can see
the allure of it you know this the the
in my less gracious moments when i felt
jilted or insulted or not wanted or
whatever i can see those areas of me
that would become seduced by that sort
of talking point you know you have this
hurt man
who
feels like the world has done him wrong
and
it's much easier to create a conspiracy
around an entire gender
that this is women at large as opposed
to
maybe you just chose a shitty one man or
maybe maybe you just rolled a bad hand
maybe it was unfortunate look or poor
timing or maybe
the the particular combination of
circumstances a little bit of you and a
lot of them or a lot of them and
whatever
that caused a bad situation to come out
of it and for some reason it's more
comforting to believe that this is a
uh a
pandemic at large that only affects one
half of the population
it's you know and and both sides say it
both sides feminists say every man is a
potential rapist and and men say every
woman is a potential divorce rapist
she'll take all your money
both sides do it and there's a lot of
money in it there's a lot of political
power in it both political parties are
deeply invested in these these things
and whole nations are turning on these
ideas it's not just the internet it's
it's the world right now yeah there's um
meme culture's so [ __ ] smart man i'm
sure that you'll have seen this one it's
these two dudes these two um black
illustrations of guys with beards and it
says a woman hurt me and i never made up
about it uh we should call ourselves
alpha males and then they just walk away
you think [ __ ] man like
the the main problem that i have with
the red pill space is that
almost none of the guys that are in that
space look to me like the alpha males
that i would want to follow none of them
embody the sort of actual genuine
integrity trustworthiness honor um
sensitivity
uh genuine masculinity none of the guys
embody that it's just
i don't know it's the equivalent of a
girl replacing beauty with a boob job
and lip fillers you know it's all it's
all front no substance does that make
sense very much absolutely because
the understanding red bill it's really
just evolutionary psychology that's
applied that's all it is
taking it on and saying i am a red pill
man means you have got stuck there if
you get out of a bad relationship you
should learn evolutionary psychology
about what women actually biologically
want from you and about attachment you
should learn those things red pill is
right now the only place where men can
speak these old truths that fathers
would have said to their sons like well
son let me tell you about women red pill
is the only area men can go to hear that
now because we don't have relationships
with our fathers or grandfathers or
uncles anymore we don't have male only
spaces red pill is the only area where
they can do that
so they go there and they learn these
things and the men who are good and
healthy i shouldn't say good people but
they're healthy
they move on they learn it and then they
move on into something else they learn
they move into
their church system or they move into an
honor culture with an honor tribe online
they move into masculinity groups
instead of red pill groups they move
into married men support groups where
they're building each other up good ones
um they move into fraternities and
things in programs like that they don't
get stuck and say i'm a red bill men
when you do that
that means you really are stuck and you
really need to move out of that group
it's a good on-ramp but it's not the
highway and we can replace red pill with
extreme feminism right you know and
basically get the exact same situation
coming out have you looked at black pill
or the in-cell culture much
you know
i've worked with a lot of them i know a
lot of them not that like in cell's a
movement but i mean i know a lot of
dudes who are in cell i know a lot of
dudes who are black pill um those are
those could be two different things um
it hurts it hurts when they're going
through and i understand a lot of it is
built on a lot of it's built on
attachment issues not all of it but a
lot of in-sell things are built on
attachment issues and they don't
understand how or why and they do need
applied evolutionary psychology to
understand like why are women not
attracted to me well let's talk about
that let's talk about what women
biologically want and then let's talk
about the culture of things that are
also in tune and we can get you a
girlfriend man i teach courses i teach
dudes how to get girlfriends and it
works like that how to get married i had
one dude i taught him how to get married
he went from men i don't know i don't
know how to do this he got married like
three like man he got a engaged three
months after i taught him he got engaged
and he got married they've been happily
married for years now like you can learn
this and apply it and it's not that hard
um
but the black pill stuff man and and
giving up
it hurts it hurts to see because it
doesn't have to be that way learn
attachment learn evolutionary psychology
and then find an actual tribe of quality
men that you can connect with and you
won't feel that way anymore because
you'll start building with other people
don't feel don't be alone anymore clear
all the obstacles out of the way from
being that make you feel alone
or if you don't know how to do that talk
to somebody that's the other piece men
our brains are solution machines and we
can only pump out solutions with data we
already have if you don't have the data
you got to talk to another man who has
solved the problem get the data from him
and he'll give you that data and you
build a solution that's how our brains
work our brains men's brains we're like
the internet we're supposed to share
solutions and if you don't yeah you're
going to get stuck
what it made me realize thinking about
red pill and black pill is i had nama
katson who did a ton of research into
the in cell community and in these black
pill communities which are basically
nihilism for anyone that doesn't
understand it it's kind of like
relationship nihilism for men typically
and
what she said was that anybody that
suggests any small hint of ascending
which would be a girl in a coffee shop
smiled at me today it's not even going
for a date or i got a girl's number it's
any tiny little sliver of attention from
the female gender
that as soon as you do that as soon as
you show in any of these forums these
black pill forums that you may have had
a little bit of
attention as soon as you show that
that's you out you're ostracized from
the group and the reason for that is
that it gives undue the subtext for the
reason for that is it gives undue hope
to the other people in that group well
if this guy has managed it then maybe so
am i and it's i
how would you say
it's a loyalty it's a show of loyalty
that you're not prepared to try and
ascend right it is a um a sacrifice for
the group look i'm putting the interests
of the group over the interests of my
own happiness and i think in red pill
it's almost the same
that it's a um a commitment to
seeing women as a means to an end to
committing to this particular narrative
around them being gold diggers or being
able to move from man to man very very
quickly dude like
the world that these guys exist in
seems very very detached from mine i've
spent a lot of time around a lot of
girls all of whom are in that single
party girl mode who are about to move
into becoming someone that wants to get
married and settle down and have kids a
man like when those girls find the guy
they everything gets switched off i've
seen the biggest [ __ ] that have worked
for us
that had just a different guy every
night of the week they would be moving
between different parties different
groups and then as soon as they find
someone that they care about that mode
just gets killed i'm like this this this
isn't the case but
when you're in a community of an echo
chamber of that and you're probably not
spending a whole lot of time in the real
world to disprove these ideas
that's all that you can see
and you know what most of those women in
that party mode are there because it's
attachment issues they're there because
that's all they know that's how they
know how to feel good and get attention
they're using sex to get love most women
i mean those are the visible women
that's the problem those are the visible
women you know where most women are
they're at home they're families they're
watching tv they're knitting they're
they're coloring they're playing video
games they're petting their cat they're
sitting with their family and having a
good time that's where most women are
and you will not be introduced to those
good women because the people you know
are going to look at you as a disaster
not you but i mean red pill dudes and
black pill dudes
other women and your your family and
friends aren't going to say hey you
should meet this wonderful woman i know
who's like 22
she's never ever had a boyfriend she's
just sweet and she just wants to be a
mom
they're not going to say hey dude you're
like smoking pot you don't have a job
all you do is yell and complain about
women and you're trying to bang all
these women in the club i should
introduce you to this great young woman
i know yeah no that's not how the game
works man so you're only going to see
these visible women at the club you're
like she's sleeping with somebody every
night why not me why am i the only man
in town she hasn't slept with you know
that's not a great place to be
um but yeah man when women when women
know they know when when women see you
and they see that your value they attach
to you with claws and they will never
ever let go and they will sleep outside
on your front porch until you open the
door when a woman really loves you
that's how far they go um and i know
this because i've been with my wife like
14 years and if i tried to walk out the
door she would handcuff me to her like
it is what it is women know
and when they get in good relationships
they start to heal they instinctively
build self-correcting networks a healthy
woman instinctively builds
self-correcting networks
they just do
especially once they have children then
they really start building
self-correcting networks suddenly
attachment problems that you both had in
the beginning of the relationship are
now a problem and she starts looking at
you as the threat to the kids because
the kids aren't building good attachment
with you that's where a lot of divorces
come in when women become moms most
women
they want to fix their attachment issues
but they don't know how and now they're
angry at you for having attachment
issues yeah i mean fix your attachment
issues it doesn't happen this came up in
the first episode where you said that a
lot of issues that women have in
marriages where there's kids isn't
necessarily to do with their
relationship with the father it's the
father's relationship with the children
that the woman is now being very
protective over the kid's life and she
sees that the man is not being the
father that she wanted
and that causes a defense mechanism to
kick in which actually creates friction
between man and woman
that's what i tell men when when your
kids are like 10 years old or 12 years
old or even teens and she's going at you
and it looks like she wants to kill you
and she's mentioning divorce
there is no way on earth you can fix
your relationship with her unless you
fix your relationships with your kids
first and if you fix your relationships
with your kids first that automatically
just about fixes the relationship with
her because all of a sudden all the
problems she had with you is now great
and the kids are talking about how great
you are and she sees you with them and
her oxytocin starts flowing or dopamine
every time she looks at you and the kids
and they are laughing and hugging you
and smiling her brain automatically
makes her like you more because you are
good for those kids that's this is this
is what red pill should be teaching this
is applied evolutionary psychology it's
all it is her brain releases dopamine
oxytocin vasopressin all kinds all kinds
of bonding chemicals when she sees you
with the kids and the kids are happy to
be with you if you can fix that
man that's like it's like putting your
marriage on easy mode if you put if you
if your relationship with your kids is
rocky or distant and the kids are
nervous and anxious all the time man
you're putting your marriage on hard
mode then it's good luck getting a smile
out of her that would be a man's
manosphere movement that i would totally
totally get behind if it was more to do
with okay how do we make a marriage as
sick as possible like how do we make a
marriage as awesome as easy as possible
because you know
end of the day that's kind of what men
would like we've still got other [ __ ]
that we want to try and do
but the you know the goals in the gym or
the sport team that we play on a weekend
or the bike that we're obsessively
fixing when we get home from work
being able to do okay how do i make the
marriages as easy and comfortable and
also because you care about the partner
and so on and so forth yeah man that
would be someone someone out there
should create
uh a branch off of red pill that is
about married men becoming better
married men and the same the same for
women as well you know understanding
evolutionary psychology and not just
this
tribal hatred right next one next one
this is dude this tweet of yours went
[ __ ] berserk reminded that your kids
should leave home at 18 is a psyop by
the central banks to make 10 extended
family members pay 10 rents mortgages 10
sets of utilities 10 car payments and 10
of every item needed for a home plus
entertainment and stress relief to cope
with being alone what's this all about
man people lost it at this um
people aren't meant to live alone we're
not meant to have a studio apartment
where we never see our family covet has
made that clear i hope to most people
that we're not meant to live completely
isolated from everybody else
um does that mean you have to live in a
one-room shack with 50 family members
well no there's a balance point and
everybody every family has a balance
point but making it the culturally
understood norm that every single family
is going to split off into a nuclear
family and the kids will instantly leave
at 18 that you should throw them out or
they have failed and you have failed as
a parent making that the system
man look at our society right now what
would our society look like
assuming healthy attachment if we fixed
all of the attachment problems and so
families could honestly lovingly
communicate meet each other's needs and
we're in a bunch of cold brutal jerks to
each other i'm looking at the boomer
generation if if families actually loved
each other and cared about each other
and did what was right for each other
instead of just for themselves
imagine living in a big collective group
in a big house like 40 acres
maybe two or three houses living all
together in a small family village
basically yeah you could even have your
own space you could even build five
houses on one property and you have five
nuclear families
all within spinning distance of each
other so when you as a garage a new
parent are exhausted you can call your
mom over and she's like oh yeah okay
sister or auntie or grandmother or
sister or auntie or grandmother look at
kids man if
if your dad dies you don't have a dad to
raise you your dad you let's say you
have a scumbag dad and he leaves
you have like five uncles and a
grandfather five other surrogate fathers
there all of whom are actually
genetically invested
and all of them if they have good
attachment can come to you and say all
right man let's talk about your dad and
let's talk about why his choice is not
your fault and they fix that attachment
with you and you grow up knowing how to
be a man and how to love women and care
for women and they aren't and they're
your red pill group they say let me tell
you about women and how to have a good
loving healthy marriage that fulfills
you and your wife at the same time so
you can raise good healthy children matt
that that was normal
normal a hundred years ago
everything i'm talking about was normal
100 years ago let's go back 150 years
ago i'm here in the united states
civil war era man families lived either
together or they split up in tiny
nuclear families on adjacent farms fam
people didn't even travel more than like
20 miles from their home in their entire
life most people they stayed close for a
reason family businesses family jobs you
didn't take on debt
about 100 years ago
central banks really took over really
hard we had a lot of changes and all of
a sudden it became a debt system and we
look at the 1920s we look at the rise of
credit the credit system look at the
rise of basically sanctioned gambling
with the stock market the 1920s nose
dived hard and they said
yeah that's a that's a problem let's
just keep doing the same system but take
even more control and do it even more
the
families and attachments broke and broke
and broke and broke until it became in
the 1960s and 70s screw the old people
they don't know what's right for you you
should take all the money for yourself
and get out from under their thumb so
you can have sex in your car at walmart
with you know not walmart it was a diner
back then you could have sex on on the
cliff at make out point with your
girlfriend and you could do all the cool
stuff screw the old people they just
don't want you to be happy and that's
that messaging hit and hit and hit and
hit and hit everywhere in every part of
our culture not by accident
man you look at all the things that
they've done over the last even the last
50 years it's horrible and it's it's
really beneficial for the people who
profit off of it it's really beneficial
to have kick your kid out at 18 have
them be miserable put them on
antidepressants have them get fat and
miserable because they're coping with
sugary foods put them on more
medications blood pressure medications
at 30 put them on insulin put them on
everything put them in front of a tv
screen because they have no friends so
they just stream and stream and stream
they'll pay for all of your services
they'll pay for endless escapist
entertainment and they'll just sit there
pumping cash into the system over and
over and over until they die that's the
system right now that's why we have a
suicide epidemic that's why we have
overdose epidemics the drug epidemics
did you know i was reading the news the
other day heroin addicts here in america
are getting pretty nostalgic for actual
heroin because fentanyl is covering the
market so hard and it's so hard to find
good old-fashioned heroin that isn't
going to kill you as much [ __ ] there's
going to be like a vintage hipster
culture for heroin
heroin classic it's like classic
yeah the only other one we all love
needles nowadays so i am i i think i
messaged you about this a while ago
before you did that tweet saying how
strange it is that we don't have pan
generational houses anymore you know you
have like a cut like a commune or
whatever and
you know i've got a lot of wanderlust
i'm out here in austin at the moment in
texas from the uk because i like to go
to different places but if you had a hub
if you had a large family center that
doesn't mean that individual people
can't go off and live their own life but
it creates a home base that's
significantly more stable than just oh
well that's mum and dad's house i go
back at thanksgiving or christmas each
year
correct here in the united states it's
even worse than that you buy a house you
raise kids the moment they're out of the
house you sell the house and you move
into a one bedroom downsized again yeah
then you don't even have a family house
anymore that old song you can't go home
well you really can't go home in america
because they've torn down your house or
someone else is living or someone else
is living there shooting up heroin old
classic heroine yeah old-school heroine
right next one i love you but i'm not in
love with you is a recipe for five
divorces
what do you think what do people mean
when they say i love you but i'm not in
love with you
typically it's women who say it and
typically what it means is i don't
respect you it means i love you like i
would love a helpless child but i don't
respect you as an actual man because
you're not a strong provider you have no
honor and you have no staying power with
any of your words so i can't trust you
so i don't
feel romantic love towards you that's
really what that's code for so if your
wife ever says i love you but i'm not in
love with you it means you are not a
high quality man and i don't trust you
that's what that means point blank
um
saying it
means she and he both don't understand
what's actually going on because we
don't say
you know i want to love you and be in
this marriage but i just don't respect
you and that's making it hard so if he
is the man who can't engender respect
from women and if she doesn't know how
to phrase it that way
yeah that's five that's five divorces
right there before you actually learn
what's wrong and this is a man who's not
sticking to his word who's untrustworthy
lack of integrity lack of honor
man attachment does that because you
have to play everybody else's game and
make everybody else night happy which
means you have to be the perfect nice
guy which means you have to be a
cardboard cutout with no opinions no
values no cut no honor no nothing
all of that would get in the way of
making everybody else like you so you
gotta have nothing and it's impossible
for a woman to respect a man like that
which means she's gonna have zero sex
drive at least after the initial opening
phase of the relationship to attract you
her sex drive is gonna nose dive
and she's gonna hit you with i love you
but i'm not in love with you and i'm in
love with this other dude over here
next one
during sex men and women bond
differently women experience a surge of
oxytocin during orgasm which binds them
to their partner but research indicates
men don't experience the same bonding
response men have far much more
vasopressin receptors than women and
they don't appear to experience as many
large oxytocin events like female orgasm
vaginal birth breast feeding men may
bond more through vasopressin what's all
this
vasopressin is an older hormone that
predates oxytocin in the human species
in the mammal species oxytocin joined
into the mammal species um our oxytocin
receptors seem to have formed when
mammals began to lactate lactation is
oxytocin in a big way um it allowed
women to give vaginal birth and
experience a lot of oxytocin which is
why women a lot of women
who plan to
adopt their baby out at birth instantly
can't because now they're in love with
the baby they've got a flood of oxytocin
through vaginal birth and the first time
they breastfeed every time they
breastfeed they get a flood of oxytocin
the baby gets a flood of oxytocin the
wife the woman also experiences a flood
of oxytocin during orgasm she gets
oxytocin when holding hands when talking
when cuddling
sharing feelings oxytocin flood men
don't really get that we do have some
oxytocin but men seem to have a lot more
vasopressin which is stress
it's you and me
we hate each other's guts but we have to
feed our families so we go out together
and we hunt a mammoth and kill it and
and we realize we can rely on each other
and now we are bonded for life all of a
sudden we're best friends because we
killed a mammoth it's two dudes being
mad at each other and beating the crap
out of each other and then at the end of
it the other one dude offers his hand
picks the other guy up off the ground
they shake hands and they are best
friends for the rest of their life
that is vasopressin it's bonding through
stress and it happens and we men we bond
better through stress which is why when
a baby is born a newborn baby the
fathers don't usually bond with a
newborn baby right away they love the
baby but they don't feel close to the
baby until they can start teaching their
child things a little bit of stress and
applying a solution solving a problem
together bonds them with that child and
bonds up a child to them so men during
sex we experience vasopressin when we
are solving a problem together so if the
woman is really vocal about how to give
her an orgasm and says here's what we're
gonna do and he says yeah let's do that
he will do it and he will feel really
bonded to her because he achieved her
orgasm together if he sets out he's like
all right tonight we're doing a hundred
orgasms and she says i don't want 100
orgasms what he hears is i don't want to
solve problems with you and so he goes
oh you don't want any really
well i don't want none but it goes back
and forth a lot of women think they're
giving a burden to the man when they say
hey i need this to orgasm or hey more of
this less of this do this they think
they're going to be a burden really men
love it and i'm sure you can attest men
love it when a woman is vocal and
engaged and giving feedback and telling
you hey do this hey don't do that hey
more of this and it's like yeah and
vasopressin floods so he gets
vasopressin at the end when he orgasms
it's a culmination of all of that see
it's a vassar press and flood doesn't
work if she's just laying there like all
right we're going to make this about you
just do what you got to do i'll just
close my eyes and think of england you
know it just doesn't work that way so
it's a combination it's a combination of
porn and an ikea how to put it together
manual that's the optimal there you go
there you go swinging swinging from the
chandelier screaming at the top of your
lungs yes go for it no it's um
it's just introducing a little bit of
stress it's team building exercises it's
doing something fun where you together
are solving a problem if you give your
man a problem to solve during sex he
will solve it and he will feel really
great and he will bond to you the way
that you were born like if you need if
you need the back end of your website
reconfiguring if you need to reprogram
some codes during sex that's also a term
exactly during during just put the
laptop on your back
yeah i remember again one of my favorite
lessons that you gave us in the first
episode was
the men that were comatosed during the
second world war and then got up and
started driving ambulances and fire
trucks because they were given a purpose
and the ability to achieve that purpose
and that was such a motivating force for
men and this am i right in saying that
it's not precisely the same mechanism
but it's a similar sort of process that
men are going through problem problem
requires solution i'm a person that does
things not people i'm a person that
needs to fix problems as opposed to just
dwell on them
big time big time it's also why men
during war bonds so hard with the other
men in their squad even if they were
only together for a year they are
lifelong friends and they can pick right
back up even when they're 85 years old
and have a reunion this is why it's
because they vast oppressive bonded to
those men so hard if women can learn to
stress bond with men a little bit better
man you're gonna have him in your life
forever that's and the opposite is also
true if you don't stress bond him to you
at all those are the women who get
really really powerful feelings because
their oxytocin flood from their
orgasming with their one night stand
dude from tinder and he ghosts her and
she's like i thought we had a connection
well no you had a chemical connection
and you didn't chemical connection him
to you at all so he's gone but the women
who come out and say i'm gonna make sure
you never forget me and they put and
that right there is a stress statement
but you put him through a little bit of
stress he really never will forget you
he'll be bonded to you for life
needing to be right will keep you
friendless and stupid
i have learned that myself
um
on the surface it's just arguing being
argumentative and needing to be right
but
needing to be right also covers never
asking questions it covers never saying
no i've never heard of that tell me
about that it covers never saying hey
could you teach me more about that you
seem really smart it covers all of that
if you automatically assume you are
right or if you at least have to express
to other people that you are right so
you don't look like an idiot you will
always be an idiot and you will have no
friends again that's a press and bonding
men bond through teaching each other
also so asking another dude hey no i've
never heard about that can you tell me
more that's a press and bond and you're
going to learn at the same time
the dumb thing about conversations
is that you know almost all of the stuff
that you're going to say every so often
you link together different concepts
that you never have done before but
that's usually in a conversation that's
a back and forth and like you know i
i can't switch that off now it's been
trained through this [ __ ] podcast and
now i've become infected so that i ask i
ask far too many questions even when
there's not a microphone on but
you know all of the stuff that you
already know you don't know any of the
things that the other person knows
so oddly the most selfish thing that you
can do in a conversation is to be
selfless and ask a ton of questions you
end up gaining all of this information
from whoever else it is the only problem
or one of the reasons i can see perhaps
why people don't fall into this routine
is that they're friends with people that
genuinely don't interest them they're
friends with people out of convenience
as opposed to an actual bond or there
being a high value and that can
that can be part of it is attachment if
the belief is that there's something
wrong with you deep down that nobody
else everybody else can see and you
don't know what it is you never want to
expose your lack of knowledge you have
to constantly say yeah i totally know
what that is i really know what that is
and and you don't say hey can you teach
me because the other person will say you
don't know about that or they're going
to say no i'm not going to spend the
time teaching you it's the constant fear
of rejection and fear of abandonment
which ultimately turns every
conversation into a game of if you ever
play guitar hero where you got to hit
all the buttons perfect to get the right
outcomes it's just you pushing the right
buttons to make the other person like
you at every single step that's all it
is so it's not even a conversation it's
it's you playing a video game on the
other person and the other person trying
to talk to you which is why healthy
people don't really like to talk to
people who have attachment problems
because it's not a conversation it's not
like this it's not back and forth it's
not fun it's it's somebody else playing
a video game on you and treating you
like an object the first time i ever
heard this was eckhart tolle and he said
that
people who can't bear to be proved wrong
are worried about ego destruction that
they
um
they see
being shown to be wrong as complete
dissolving of what they are internally
and yeah the more that you can ask a
question and say
actually that that's i don't even know
what that is i've never heard of that
before how does that work the more that
you get yourself into the routine of
feeling like somebody that can be wrong
without feeling fear
and i will say this if a man says that
to you
get a chance to teach him you've
suppress and bond by teaching him so
asking those questions especially of
other men makes them like you
yeah man uh next one
young women when they're single i'm a
fierce tiger made of unicorns no man can
tame me young women in a relationship
i'm so worthless nobody loves me please
don't leave me if this is you this is a
sign of broken attachment
yeah heck yeah this this is this is
women who have broken attachment because
outside of a relationship they have to
constantly signal that they're strong
and that they have no weaknesses and
nobody can help them no one can tame
them no one can stop them it's a fear
projection it's it's in nature it's a
bird fluffing up to look five times its
size so the predator won't eat it
it's it's messaging to themselves to
cope with the pain of having lost
relationships well they just couldn't
handle me um it's if you don't if you
can't handle me at my worst you don't
deserve me at my best it's that
messaging all over again but the moment
they bond with somebody the oxytocin
bond um the way oxytocin works is if you
have not had much of it especially in a
childhood with neglect or abuse your
brain shifts to be very jealous and
protective of what does give you an
oxytocin bond so if a man gives you
orgasms and love and care all of a
sudden you shift to be very paranoid
about losing that attachment bond at
oxytocin and if you have bad attachment
you believe you are playing in a
constant deficit all the time so you
have to earn his constant love and
approval by being perfect
all the time and never ever bothering
him which means never challenging him
never stressing him so he'll never vast
the present bond to you
so this bond just never happens it over
happens on your side and it under
happens on his side and it just destroys
you and that's the women who are
ragingly furious and angry and strong
outside of relationships and completely
crumble behind closed doors and will do
anything for their man no matter how
many principles of theirs it violates
that's why that happens yeah we all know
this that's right we all know the the
girl that is a real hard ass when she's
single i don't need no man and then
i don't know it's so bad because
hypocrisy and calling out somebody for
their own lack of self-awareness is so
inherently satisfying this is one of the
problems that we have with people that
are up themselves on the internet that
you have a a catalog of pretty much
everything that you've ever said and if
you start to turn against that without
calling out and going uh actually i was
wrong about this thing i thought i was
whatever whatever and now i'm not if you
just continue on and start to contradict
yourself people adore calling out
hypocrisy they absolutely love it and
the problem that you have in a situation
like this is if you have a woman that's
a real hard ass when she's single and a
real soft touch when she's in a
relationship
no one
really
feels much empathy
for them
because they haven't called out uh
actually i thought that i was a strong
woman that didn't need no man and now
i'm really really happy in this
relationship and for anybody else out
there that feels the same uh maybe maybe
you should sort of consider that this
could be a good route for you as well
that's the sort of thing where you go
wow this person's actually identified
that they were in the wrong they've now
given a piece of advice to other people
yep there we go but when you just flip
flop from one to the other
there's no sympathy there
no and and and then the two
distinguishing pieces are when a woman
has healed her attachment in the
relationship she will say man i was so
wrong and when she has not healed her
attachment in the relationship when the
attachment issue persists she will start
getting defensive no i'm still totally
an independent woman and it'll start to
really impact her brain because she's
trying to hold a paradox in her brain
she has cognitive dissonance i'm a hard
independent woman who can't bear even
five minutes away from my boyfriend it's
it and it just rips her apart and it
rips the relationship apart too she'll
start to resent him for making her weak
she'll start to resent the people who
point it out to her she'll try to hold
both in her head and it just it destroys
her those are the women who need
sympathy the most but they engender the
least sympathy because like you said the
hypocrisy is there they're defensive
they're angry and they can't seem to
stay loyal to either side they look like
they have no loyalty at all in fact
what's happening is they have so much
loyalty and so much desperate love
that they don't believe they deserve any
love back they're such a good such a
good point the fact that they're the
ones that need the most sympathy but
cultivate the least so interesting
right love is not a feeling love is
taking consistent action that's truly
best for someone especially when it's
against your self-interest the more it
costs you the greater your love if you
feel affection but never sacrifice for
that person you only like the idea of
loving them
man i think of my kids i think of my
kids i'm a father which means
i'm going to sacrifice for my kids
there's times where my kids men they're
like one of my kids is three
if she
gets mad she'll yell she'll throw toys
usually not she's usually pretty well
behaved but when she's tired when she
has a bad day
i can either vent my anger at her and
feel good by myself yelling at her and
screaming at her
or i can
tone it down i can put myself aside i
can put my own dopamine levels aside and
say let's not worry about me right now
let's worry about taking care of you and
give her the love and attention she
needs and teach her
gently the way that she needs to learn
so that she can behave better
that right there is sacrifice that right
there is love it love is an action i am
loving my child i feel affection toward
my kid but love is not proven
until you actually do something about it
if i just scream at my daughter all the
time
and start screaming you're a brat i
can't stand you why are you doing this
to me why would you treat me this way
well she's three
i'm not three
i'm supposed to be the parent i'm
supposed to love her and give her that
love
if she's doing something bad and i just
say oh that's okay sweetie i'm also not
loving her i'm being affectionate in my
heart i have affection for her but i'm
spoiling her i'm ruining her life
love is action if you love somebody then
you must prove it you must do it love is
it's a verb to love is a verb
people don't get that there's a lot of
people out there who think they're the
best parents on earth because they
tolerate their kids
there's a lot of parents out there who
think that they're the best parents
because they tolerate what their kids do
and they resent their kids for the
sacrifices they have to make i never
i should say
i'm not going to say this carefully so
i'm honest
there are times when parents
might resent they might be you have to
catch yourself and realize you are being
a piece of crap and a selfish person and
you are not loving your child by
resenting your child you are not loving
your child even in your heart you are
not loving your child you have to choose
to love your child same thing in
marriage same thing in friendships same
thing in every relationship you must
choose to love somebody or you only like
the idea of loving them you like the
idea of being a loving person you like
the idea of being a good parent more
than you are willing to be a good parent
and that's it love is action if you
don't take action you don't love
this is related to another one that you
did step one isn't to figure out the
solution it's to shut down your
emotional right brain and restore energy
to your logical left brain so you can
process the situation in a calm way
right so and i don't know if my camera's
reversed but the right side of your
brain is emotion and creativity and all
kinds of stuff the left side of your
brain is logic it's it's math it's also
language things like this over here um
your brain only has so much energy
between it between the hemispheres to
jump back and forth and have ideas and
make connections um you when you become
emotional it diminishes the logical
brain to fuel and a storm on this brain
so it's rapidly connecting all the
feelings and figuring out how to fix it
now you let your right brain all its
good force figure out how to maximize
your pleasure and minimize your pain for
the next five seconds
if you are emotional that's the brain
you're thinking with and this brain is
logically diminished if you take a brain
scan of someone who's very emotional it
looks like north and south korea at
night one is lit up and one is dark and
it gets worse the more emotions you
experience and especially if you've got
trauma if you've got things like that it
gets worse and worse and worse
so when you are triggered by something
troubled bothered whatever the problem
is the problem you shouldn't be solving
it when your brain's like this you need
to calm yourself down so that your brain
restores logical functioning and then
you'll start thinking longer term than
five seconds you'll start saying what
should i do long-term what are my
principles what are my long-term goals
what do i actually want to accomplish
here for the relationship instead of
maximize pleasure minimize pain for five
seconds that's that's that should be
your first step whenever you are upset
by something is to restore logical
functioning the solution will come to
you after that
this one is something i think should be
a
disclaimer above every person's twitter
twitter is too short for specifics
generalizations have to suffice midwits
can't abide generalizations they'll
point out every exception and demand you
tweet a full thread then they refuse to
read full threads don't tweet for
midwits they're not your audience
and it's true
um
and i say midwifes that's me being kind
of a jerk
what i mean is those people who don't
invest in understanding because there's
people who are beginners into an un into
any topic there's people who are
advanced and entert any topic and there
are people who are right in the middle
who are trying to figure out what
exceptions exist to the rules those are
the people who go and say well
you say this for men and women but i
knew a woman once who wasn't that way so
you are wrong you are completely wrong
and they get angry at you for not
tweeting
50 different tweets after your one tweet
then you need 50 different tweets with
every possible exception listed that any
human could ever make
um
and they demand it and they get upset if
you don't and they think they have won
the argument and proven you wrong this
imaginary argument they're having with
you um
don't tweet for those people number one
i mean sometimes they aren't i don't
wanna say sometimes they're not
intelligent enough to understand it
usually they don't understand the topic
enough to understand that picking out
all the exceptions does not make you a
smart person
they aren't willing to generalize and
accept like this is for most people some
things aren't for you some things are
not for you and if you imagine
everything on earth has to be for you
maybe fix you
what did people [ __ ] think did they
think that this 280 character post was
going to cover every different anomalous
situation for all of time no obviously
not and
actually
should be banned on twitter actually
any tweet that begins with the word
actually should just be immediately
censored because yeah you can just mute
that person that person from them
obviously obviously it's not meant i've
had to sacrifice
specificity for brevity online the
reason that tweets do well is because
they're pithy and because they're kind
of they sort of snappy and they sound
cool and they have got a sense of
generalization in if you want to come in
as the guy that identifies the fact that
there is actually an outlier to this
situation
what are you proving you're proving the
fact that somebody's had to sacrifice
specificity for brevity like [ __ ]
well done you five internet points
and you know there there used to be a
saying
that somehow people have forgotten
and the saying is this
the exception proves the rule
the exception proves that the rule
exists if you have to rack your brain to
think of the one woman on earth who
wasn't born with feet so that you can
say how dare you say women are born with
feet
well the exception proves the rule
there's one woman over there who was
born without feet okay i get that they
exist but saying yeah women are born
with feet
it's not it should not be an arguable
statement some of these statements i
make in my twit tweet thread people get
so ragingly angry because they're like
well that's not me how dare you say this
is true
well it's true for most people and if
it's not true for you cool move on
but if they're getting that angry
man there's something there
like maybe someone else made them feel
bad that they don't fit into that one
and that's usually what they're arguing
against they're not arguing against you
they're arguing against the one person
in their past history who made them feel
bad for being an exception that's really
where that a lot of that comes from the
problem as well if you're someone that's
trying to create a platform online or
trying to just get messaging out there
if you try and caveat everything that
you say you're going to erode out all of
the color and the flavor that actually
makes it exciting in the first place if
you decide to caveat every tweet that
you do with i know that it's not about
this and on average and then explain
what on average actually means if you do
that then all the sexiness of your
content's been lost in any case so yeah
yeah not optimizing for midwits i think
is
it's just not man a very good idea
if you optimize for midwich you'll have
one follower and that will be your mom
who says you are really clever nobody
else wants to follow you because they're
like they'll everyone else be like man i
want to follow this guy all he does is
tweet like some
maybe averages that doesn't really help
me because then he's not even saying
what average people can do i
sometimes if it's a really hot topic the
second tweet the first sentence of the
second tweet will be
some people are different and i'll have
that in there like not everybody but the
majority and the output but the majority
and then i just launched from there and
that's the second tweet and when when
people hit me and say well that's not ev
i just grabbed that tweet i copy a link
to it and i just go through the comments
uh here's somebody and i just post that
tweet at them not even saying anything
else because i know they didn't even
bother to read the thread yeah women are
insecure about details men don't notice
details men notice body parts no man
ever said hey one of her nipples is
slightly larger than the other but every
woman knows which of her nipples is
larger than the other and is terrified
her partner will leave her for it
most women spend their time worrying
about the man they love noticing
imperfections that only another woman
would notice few women realize that you
cover imperfections by distracting men
with accentuated body parts flaunt what
you've got he won't care about the rest
i think i should win a nobel prize for
that one because that solves like all
female insecurity right we're done no
it's true women don't get this if you
take off your shirt
and
your husband is staring at you he is not
going to notice that you have a mole
next to your belly button he is going to
be staring at the two things that are
right there in front of him and if
you're completely naked he'll be his
eyes will be making a triangle left
right and down and that's all he's going
to be looking at and he might look at
your face maybe he probably won't even
notice you could wear you could wear a
fake mustache with completely naked and
he it would take him three hours to
notice the fake mustache and that's not
your laugh because it's true
it is so true
we don't know we notice body parts and
we fixate on body parts um especially
the ones we like we're just we just do
men look at the specifics that we are
trying to do because we're trying to
achieve an objective her shirt is off i
should maximize the amount of time i can
stare at these two things that's usually
what we're doing and then we're getting
aroused and then we say hey we should
have sex we aren't looking at her body
going hmm
that's interesting she has a mole there
i wonder where that when that mole came
up hey she has a tiny scar on behind her
ankle i wonder where that scar came from
i would like to know that story now we
are pretty fixated on getting done the
job that we want to get done and that's
just just what it is that's where we're
at so if women
can find out their three best features
and augment those three best features in
whatever way
man you have it made mike just do that
do that and see if he even notices
anything you know what if a woman walked
in a room completely naked
with a false mustache
it would be amazing if her husband
noticed the false mustache within like
a while
do that test women at home buy a false
mustache probably find them on amazon
and see do the false mustache test see
if your husband even notices walk in
completely butt naked
and
back to him first so he sees your butt
and then turn around he won't even
notice your face the moustache will be
there for a while and when he does
you'll have to say so what do you think
of my mustache he'll go huh and then
he'll jump because he's so shocked
give that a try do the do the mustache
test and that will show you how little
he cares about your imperfections
pro tip if you share that someone has
hurt you and their first response is to
complain that your admission hurts them
they don't love you
that's true man a lot of people when
they try to fix their attachment they
ask me should i tell my parents
and my answer is usually no because your
relationship formed in that environment
first you need to fix your attachment
with at least three other people so you
have the emotional backing from other
people to be able to go to your parents
if they hit you with how dare you do
this to me
um if the other person says how dare you
show this to me why are you doing this
now what's the problem their first
thought isn't wow the person i love is
hurt i need to help them
and if you love somebody really love
somebody you actively love them goes
right back to that you show love for
them by caring for them if you have a
selfish thought and say oh this hurts
you stop yourself and say wait a minute
this person i care about is really hurt
i need to solve this first
i'm thinking man again i'm a father if
my kids came to me and said dad it
really bothered me when you yelled at me
in front of my kids
my first if i'm a loving father my first
thought isn't
you deserved it my first thought is wait
a minute
this is a relationship with my kids i
don't want to screw this up because i'd
like to meet my grandchildren someday
let me think through this okay you know
what i acknowledge that you're hurt and
that sucks
talk to me about why it hurts
and then i will talk to you about why i
did it
and let's come to a compromise so we
undercut understand each other and then
going forward let's figure out how to
make sure it never happens again so that
neither one of us is bothered by this
not just me
both of us let's figure out going
forward how both of us can have this and
that's how you solve problems in a
relationship where you love each other
that's just it if the other person says
uh well you deserved it well you made me
feel bad well you hurt me first
well that's defensiveness and they don't
really love you
what about the reverse what about if you
are someone to whom somebody says that
you hurt them and you have this
compulsion to say your admission of that
hurts me
yeah first of all it's normal to have
that compulsion
but if you love that other person you
should practice loving them and practice
not being selfish so if you have again
the logical emotion if you logic spike
an emotion spike it might if if you
find yourself feeling upset you need to
check yourself immediately when someone
comes at you with something your first
thought should be
where am i at right now before you open
your mouth you can even close your mouth
you can pretend you're stroking your
mustache and thinking close your mouth
and say
where am i at right now
where am i at am i going to screw up
this relationship then you think what is
my goal right now is my goal to diminish
my pain and maximize my pleasure five
seconds or am i at a place right now
where i need to um
talk to this person and fix this
relationship do i want to know my kids
past the age of 18.
well okay if you're too hot right now to
think about that then you should say
okay
give me five minutes to cool off so i
don't so i so i'm not a jerk because i
love you and i care about this
relationship give me five minutes let me
think about this and let's meet back
here in five minutes that's okay to do
that in fact if you can't
have a calm relationship and fix it i
encourage you to say give me five
minutes because the other person might
say well that sucks but why and you
could say
because i'm really emotional right now
and i care about you and i want to fix
this and i don't trust myself right now
to be logical enough to have a good
conversation i'm just going to be a jerk
and i want to fix this so give me give
me five minutes
and they'll say all right
i suppose that's kind of similar to
if you are
a
a wife and there's a problem that's
occurred
ambushing the husband as soon as he
walks through the door with that is is
probably sub-optimal you might have had
a bad day at work you might have just
stepped through the door the particular
situation the dynamic that you're in you
know he's in put bags down from work
mode not i need to have a serious
conversation where i'm receptive to my
wife mode correct yeah and that's okay
it's called meta communication
communicating about your communication
is a good thing letting the other person
know hey right now is not a good time
because i am messed up i'm angry at this
other thing i'm stressed out it's okay
and and if you are a person who who
accidentally goes off at the other
person and says hey you know i'm
how dare you do this to me if you do
that sometimes it slips out you are not
loving that other person you have to
choose to go back in and love that other
person and apologize to them
and really do like and then i'm so sorry
i do care about you and i want to show
that i love you so let's actually talk
about your concerns i'm sorry that i
that i jumped on you like that and it'll
be hard but you can fix that
relationship
um
yeah man if if someone comes at you and
you you've hurt them fix it
fix it if you love that person then fix
it you should care about that
you should care that you hurt their
feelings more than your feelings are
being hurt by pointing out how you hurt
them you should care about them more
than you care about your temporary
discomfort because you have hurt them
which means you've wounded the
relationship
i suppose as well being
being the person the first mover that
gets past the tit for tat inertia or the
the game playing of well last time that
this happened they set the tone by not
responding in a very nice and meaningful
way um i again i can see that compulsion
you know i'm somebody that
you know if if i get badly done by
someone i i remember you know the
resentment sits there and you think okay
[ __ ] like it's your turn now
it's your turn now remember the last
time that you turned up late for dinner
well it doesn't matter i don't you can
almost feel it as you're going in you're
going out for dinner with a buddy and
you know that you're 15 minutes late you
go well yeah but he was half an hour
late last time so this is okay you go
well
you know
yeah it's a shitty way to live
it is it's really it's realistically
justifying treating someone else in a
non-loving way that's really what's
happening you are justifying treating
the other person without love
in some way
point blank
and if you think you're justified in
doing that because of what they did to
you then by all means destroy the
relationship by pointing that out and
telling them that they deserved what you
did to them
how would you advise somebody let's say
that they're in a relationship it could
be a friendship or a partnership and
they have got themselves into a um a
cycle of negative communication whether
that be this tit for tat thing or some
other sort of really poor back and forth
dynamic um how would you advise someone
broaching that and also
how important is it to set the tone at
the beginning of the relationship to
continue forward i'm going to guess
based on my experience that getting it
right first time and never having to fix
something is optimal but if you haven't
done that how do you fix it
you can't run a healthy relationship
without setting up clear expectations at
the start
the best that's the best time to do it
second best time to do it is before
there's a complete catastrophic meltdown
so do it now if anyone listening to this
hasn't set clear expectations set them
now what does that mean what's clear
expectations
uh the minimum to maintain the
relationship and what you expected out
of the relationship and what you hope to
get out of the relationship the minimum
so in a marriage uh let's not cheat on
each other would be one of the minimums
let's actually care about each other and
solve our problems together that would
be one of the minimums hey when there's
an actual problem let's please talk
about it instead of sweeping it under
the rug and trying to make up for it by
earning love and approval from each
other
these are these are basic expectations
in their relationship um set those
accept them tell the other person all
the boundaries you tell each other what
boundaries would make me leave this
relationship that calms the other person
down if they're anxious because that
tells them okay i won't leave you
outside of these clear bounds of the
rules of the game don't do these things
don't do these things right here here's
the next set of boundaries this is where
i would leave you here's the next set of
boundaries if i was that's another way
here's here's leaving you
here's annoyed at you
or angry at you here's slightly annoyed
at you here's like okay we're pretty
good here's like totally like thriving
and loving you and this should be this
spectrum of behavior so the other person
isn't feeling like they're walking on a
minefield waiting for their relationship
to detonate at any moment
set clear expectations of what you do
and don't want and be clear about it
when things pop up hey you know what i
didn't really like that that you just
did but could you do this for me instead
that would be great do it the first time
it pops up so no one's angry or
embarrassed because you haven't done it
for six months
set it right away boom clear
expectations if you don't set those
man good luck
i think um i keep on reflecting about
your advice that
women should give men problems that they
can solve in collaboration with each
other that's so
so powerful and i think that
trying to
trying to think about ways that you can
engender that i suppose that having kids
is one big problem to solve which is
maybe
a part of the bonding experience right
you know you need to get little timmy to
football practice but there's only one
car and you're at work and blah blah and
i think that that's that's a good part
of it but certainly for couples that
don't have kids or perhaps find the the
kids situation just isn't a
problem-solving thing
that would be something maybe that you
could try and communicate
would be a good idea as well why don't
we try and do
something that is a little bit of a
challenge work on the extension of the
house together work on building a side
project together why don't if one of
you's got a business why don't you
suggest that someone come in and i don't
know assist with that i'm not sure but
yeah that seems like
such a powerful bonding potential
yes absolutely do things together that
you normally wouldn't do do
uncomfortable things they say um
oxytocin bonding is bonding in the
absence of stress vasopressin bonding is
bonding in the presence of stress those
are the two different things and just a
little bit of stress even good stress
um solving problems together playing
board games together even can be a
little bit stressful building things
together like you said if she just goes
to him and says hey something is really
bothering me and i really need help
solving it can you help me
my curtains need to be hung up or you
know or my whatever this is bothering me
can you help me i'm having such an
overwhelming week
could you please do this for me because
you pick up dinner on thursday night
that would be so helpful to me if she
can just go to him and when we i mean
our ancestors would call it the honeydew
list honey please do this if if you
could just do that
give him little things of this would be
so helpful to me thank you so much and
he does it and you're like oh thank you
i mean you don't have to jump on him
naked the moment he comes through the
door with dinner but just like thank you
so much that helped me out so much like
fast suppressing for him there's the
feedback he gave you you gave him a
problem he solved it feedback
how many um how many women do you think
avoid doing that because they don't want
to be awkward [ __ ]
a lot of women do and especially when
they are in
when they have attachment issues because
they believe they don't deserve those
things and they believe that he doesn't
want to do them and he doesn't care if
they have dads who grew up being a
grumpy piece of crap who didn't want to
help out it really hammers home that
message of don't ever trust men um don't
ever ask men for anything you're not
worth it so it happens all the time man
a lot of women don't want to be
a bother or a burden and so they never
do the things that men need to bond it's
just it's so many missed opportunities
it doesn't make you a bad woman it just
makes you miss all the good
opportunities
many women in hookup culture believe
they're going to find a meaningful
connection they don't realize they're
being used for masturbation
and oh man that pissed off so many
people
and it's an ugly way to put it but it's
true because
that's what that's what those men are
doing they're not vasopressin bonding to
you number one
so really they're masturbating with your
body is really what they're doing
they're masturbating and having no
bonding connection whatsoever
so they may as well have stayed at home
and masturbated with their hand or an
object because their brain is viewing
you as an object especially if they
watch a lot of porn what they found is
that men who watch porn and men who are
shown porn and then shown pictures of
attractive women the brain operates um
it lights up the part of the brain
responsible for tool use instead of
human connection so if he's used to
watching a lot of people
go through some research shows um they
showed they showed pictures of
attractive women to men
who had uh first they would they would
either show them nothing i believe or
they'd show them
uh porn
and they'd show them one or the other
and so they'd show them the attractive
woman and the men who had no images
prior to that the brain would light up
for attack interacting with other humans
the men who were shown porn first and
then shown a non-pornographic picture of
attractive women the part of their brain
responsible for tool use would light up
[ __ ]
yeah so if you look at a lot of porn you
look at a woman and what happens your
brain says tool use i'm gonna masturbate
so he forgets you're even there if he's
used to porn also men who look watch a
lot of porn focus on acts and body parts
way more so he's staring at her boobs
and he's trying to get off to her boobs
instead of saying hey we're having a
wonderful experience together let's
really enjoy this and bond and connect
he's just trying to get off he's just
there and he's like all right we're
gonna do this we're gonna do this and
that's the dude who's yelling like 15
different
um that's the dude who's young 15
different instructions during like all
right flip around and look at me now
jump up and down that and like that's
why it's because he's recreating these
porn scenarios that he his brain he's
programmed his brain to get off to he
has built a fetish around using the
female body and different body parts so
he's just masturbating with your body at
that point and even if you're married
even if you're married he can still be
just masturbating with your body because
sex to him is a way of masturbating
because he's used to masturbating to
women on the internet
yeah i am i was reading robert wright's
book recently which
always has some it was written in the
90s when he did
when he first wrote his his book on
evolutionary psychology there's this
section in there that says the madonna
[ __ ] dichotomy and this is something
that i think
has kind of been lambasted and and
called out as as fake news but any man
knows that this is true so
anti-cocholdry technology could come in
handy not just when a man has a mate but
earlier in choosing her if available
females differ in their promiscuity and
if the more promiscuous ones tend to
make less faithful wives natural
selection might incline men to
discriminate accordingly promiscuous
women would be welcome as short-term sex
partners indeed preferable in some ways
since they can be hard with less effort
but that would make poor wife material a
dubious conduit for male parental
investment
and here we are in 2021 now all of that
is impacted by attachment so if men
believe that they are completely
worthless and that they're lucky to get
a woman who's had 500 partners
then that changes that dichotomy a
little bit it changes what they're used
to but if men fixed if every man in
america fixed his attachment
promiscuity would become really
unattractive
and this
it would all shift and women would
suddenly become
really really monogamous because it
wouldn't be tolerated right now it's hot
if a woman is out there all the time
just doing having fun and she can
attract lots of dudes and oxytocin bond
to them and feel really close to them
right now it's rewarded
because men have bad attachment if men
fix their attachment that all goes away
that all goes away
there's a stat i saw rob henderson
shared a little while ago saying that
the single biggest predictor of
extramarital sex is pre-marital sex
and i have i have heard that also i've
heard also heard that um a major
predictor for divorce is if she's had
any partners prior to that marriage she
said very few are none no partners at
all that also has a good low predictor
of low divorce risk this is one of those
things
for the you know the whys of every
generation discover the same truths that
was what shane parish tweeted a little
while ago that we are recreating
we're trying to recreate the rules that
things like religion and tradition gave
us and yeah maybe maybe there is a
a part of this where the genie's out of
the bottle a little bit you know when
you've created the pill for women and
had the women's liberation movement and
you're trying to have equality for the
sexes you need to now
rationalize and give genuine reasons for
something that was previously just
doctrine or culturally enforced without
another alternative so i understand
that
you know restricting
men and women to what seems like an
archaic way of living i understand why
that
is going to be a difficult pill to
swallow but the end goal for both men
and women should be okay what gives me
the most flourishing life
not is it the the cooler trendy or more
contemporary way of living it's does
this actually give me the outcome that i
want and this is why it's so important i
think for people to to understand and to
to um be able to
learn these sorts of lessons without an
emotional response because if you can do
that then it permits you to pick and
choose the elements from history that
are genuinely going to work for you as
opposed to just having a knee-jerk
reaction that well that's obviously the
patriarchal substrate construct trying
to keep us down because of a cisgendered
heteronormative whatever the [ __ ] right
like that's
reacting with that
casts off all of the potential
advantages that you could have got from
understanding that wisdom in the first
place um but yet recreating tradition in
a modern context it's not easy so it
doesn't surprise me that it's a hard
pill to swallow
there's a saying that society progresses
one grave at a time
um once a generation has established its
mores and its views and its beliefs
that generation has to die before the
next generation can implement their own
it's the reason they say that that's the
reason that in the book of exodus the
jews had to wander in the desert for 40
years before they could reach the
promised land was because the old
generations had to die off in the
younger generation who actually believed
it was possible to reach those could
reach that promised land and become
faithful um it's it's it's the
generations marching through and right
now man i did so much work with 12 year
olds so much work with 12 year old boys
who had moms who
do i say this in a way that won't get me
canceled off the internet moms who had
a boyfriend for every day of the week
let's just say a lot of boyfriends a lot
of drug addicts a lot of problems and
the boys would see their moms and say
i never ever want to be around any women
in my life who ever act like this i love
my mom but i never want this in my life
again because even at 12 he has to step
up and be the husband basically he has
to step up and be her husband and try to
run the house
and manage her behavior yeah so there's
almost like a there's like a breakwater
in between in between poor cultures poor
cultural norms and then it takes a
little bit of time to get over to that
there was a guy on the show uh talking
about the history of existential risk so
how humanity had come to understand its
own capacity for its own destruction and
there's a term called conceptual inertia
in that which is when a
commonly held scientific belief is
disproven
it still has a lagging effect about when
that fully even if you could disprove it
tomorrow so let's say that you go from a
geocentric to a heliocentric view of the
universe or something like that
even if it's proven even if everybody
accepts it
the human mind and culture
takes time for this to percolate through
and for all of the unheld assumptions
the unvoiced assumptions to completely
be ejected from the world and that very
well may be like you say one grave at a
time
it is one grave at a time but you know
what
i'm i'm i'm really
how do i say i am really
inspired by the 12 year olds that i do
meet um because they're out there in one
of two camps they either are
completely destroyed and they want to
kill themselves which is horrible
or they are so angry and so ready to
change the world
that they're they're going full throttle
it's it's one of the other it's a meat
grinder right now and the population who
survives is going to be the hardest
hardest strongest population out of that
and i don't say that with any joy in my
heart for the ones who are who are
suicidal and hurting um we need we need
to help them but it is such a darwin's
meat grinder right now of of the next
generation that is going to set the tone
and they have zero tolerance they have
zero zero tolerance for all the crap and
excess that their other generations have
got up to they have zero patience for
the rest of us for boomers for
millennials for gen x gen y they are
ready to not throw us into the furnace
but but they have zero tolerance and by
the time their power comes around
society's going to look a lot different
very very very different from how it
looks now because we are a good warning
to them about what doesn't work
yeah i mean that's the this sort of role
model that you never want to be right
the bad example
that's really
that's a poor situation to be in i keep
on hearing about how
one of the reasons that there's societal
discontent at the moment is because
millennials are the first generation who
on average did worse than their parents
that the future that we were promised is
something that hasn't come to fruition
but if you roll that forward for a
couple of generations and also you know
um boomers to millennials was probably
about a generation but millennials to uh
gen x and gen wires they that's not
they've started to cut
the time
uh domain down from it being 25 years so
actually now yeah around about 12 and a
half so that's how fast society's moving
but yeah when you have people who don't
do as well as their parents they start
to ask okay so maybe what i was taught
wasn't correct
as opposed to let's continue the
tradition if you do better than your
parents you say evolution of ideas has
worked absolutely great i i should just
teach my kids to do what i did because
it worked out fine for me but then if
that doesn't happen
look at the outcome we need something
new correct and maybe that new
is actually something old correct and
gen x and millennials men we got
we we are the ones who are saying
nothing works what the heck are we
supposed to do because the boomers threw
out everything that did work and created
a new system that was built just for
them in a happy little bubble of take on
all the debt you can build a tiny
nuclear family move away from your
family screw them screw the old people
they had this perfect little bubble
built for them by the economy so that
they could just feed the economy and
feed everything in
and that bubble doesn't work for anybody
else after them and right now the
boomers are tripling the divorce the
average divorce rate in their 70s they
are continuing to get divorced in their
70s and tripling the average divorce
rate right now
um
it's not working and gen x and
millennials are like
we don't know guess i'll die it's that
meme like i guess i'll just die and gen
z is coming along like what have you
people been doing and all right i guess
we're gonna burn to the ground and i'm
gonna build a cabin in the woods and
live there until i figured this out
that's gen z right now is is there the
ones recovering after the world has
melted down
adam lane smith ladies and gentlemen
people want to keep up to date with what
you're doing what have you got going on
have you got any new courses coming out
soon
oh man i'm focusing so much on youtube
right now so i've got a huge youtube
channel just look for adam lane smith
i'm on there my number one video i think
is male attachment uh it's bonding men
to women during sex some of the things
we talked about in here youtube is the
biggest place i'm pushing right now i'm
pushing out more courses down the road
i'm building all kinds of offerings so
i'm on twitter at the prometheus um
i'm all over the place so those are two
good places to find me right now i'm
also tick tock because gen z loves tik
tok so i want to see your i want to see
your tick tocks man yeah the uh youtube
channel adam's youtube channel and his
twitter and the tweet thread that this
is building off will be linked in the
show notes below so go and check those
out adam until the next time man get
some more tweets out we do this again
that's perfect i'd love to thank you
what's happening people thank you very
much for tuning in if you enjoyed that
episode then press here for a selection
of the best clips from the podcast over
the last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe
peace